a search party has assembled on the
grounds of a Catholic Church in Veracruz
most of the volunteers are the family
members of missing persons nationwide
more than 60,000 people have disappeared
since the start of the war on drugs in
2006 most are believed to be the victims
of criminal gangs or corrupt authorities
in recent years it's become commonplace
for the families of the disappeared to
participate in organized searches for
possible clandestine grave sites the
recent discovery of a human bone
fragment in this field means other human
remains could be hidden nearby Maria
Teresa belavezh traveled nearly 2,000
kilometers from her home in Sonora to
join the search sometimes for a family
member being given just a small piece of
bone can make them feel better because
they'll know that that's their family
that fragment can mean someone's parents
where children can finally have peace
false alarms are not uncommon but a few
volunteers like Mario vid gotta have
gotten quite good at spotting clues he
says he can't remember exactly how many
bodies has helped to uncover in that
time I mean yes okay I know buddy Neil
the families of the missing that have
learned and are now teaching the
government how to conduct a search these
families don't have forensics training
but we're the ones finding the bodies
this should be an embarrassment to the
Mexican government there are official
observers and police keeping watch over
the search Brigade but it's the
volunteers digging holes and sifting
through the soil that seemed to be doing
most of the work one of the most common
things that we've heard from members of
the search Brigade is that it's the
Mexican government that should be out
here in the heat and the Sun searching
for human remains this is the fifth time
a National Brigade has gathered for this
kind of search and it's the largest one
to date
by the end of the day authorities
arrived to examine the scene and
determine whether or not this site will
be counted among the more than 600
clandestine graves discovered in
Veracruz in recent years Manuel Arevalo
al-jazeera poza Rica Veracruz